David and Andrea are with us in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions hey guys how
are you hi fine thanks how are you
better than I deserve
welcome welcome what do you guys live
we're in Lexington connectin Kentucky
that's oh there you go just like that
it's not football it's not basketball
season yet it's always basketball season
in Lexington I love it now you guys are
actually playing some football this year
it's very well done I think you got a
good coach going there thank you fine so
you're here to do your debt-free scream
how much have you paid off one hundred
and eight six hundred and sixteen
thousand dollars well I love it
and how long did that take you it took
us 36 months and two weeks which was
ahead of schedule there you go good
making what kind of money during that
time we started out around 85 and
finished at 155 Wow
nothing like doubling your income in
three years what happened to cause that
well ironically I quit a job I I retired
I retired from public service and then
collected a pension and then I went and
I started consulting and Andre has been
working the whole time but during that
time in the beginning we went out and
got additional jobs we realized the cash
flow wasn't working yeah either had to
cut back more or make more and aundrea I
knew she was serious when she went out
and got a job at a shoe store oh my gosh
and never bought a shoe whoa second
parts important I got a purse store
honey always a good news okay good very
cool
so what kind of debt was this oh my gosh
it was credit cards and something you're
gonna really hate we borrowed against a
401 to live and we just paid it all off
oh wow a lot of it was really I guess
interest on the credit cards because we
didn't haven't bought anything in the
last three years so that was just very
sickening to what we were doing that Wow
ouch
so tell me the story what happened 36
months ago that caused you guys to dive
in like this well Dave Ben found an
article in the paper about you and I
talked about the book and suggested I
read the article and I thought well we
don't have a problem because we're still
paying our bills and
read the article and thought well you
know maybe we do have a little bit of a
problem and got the book and we started
a Labor Day in 2012 so the total money
makeover book oh it's the blue cover
the complete money maker the complete
guide to money yeah Wow okay and one
thing you said there that really kind of
bothered me or got to me was that you
said you talked about the kids
we were always taught get a credit card
pay a little bit each month and build up
your credit just don't pay it off in
full so you couldn't get more credit to
buy more stuff and that's how we were
taught and then you said the opposite in
it that's what we've been telling our
kids so we have stopped it all very cool
and how old are your kids 20 and 22 oh
very cool yeah they got a fresh start
then they weren't happy at first our
teenage son would come home and one know
where all the food was I'm like five
more days till the beginning of the
month make it work slices of bread and
some milk and some cereal beans and rice
Bubba that's how it happens oh my god
you went for it very cool so did people
make fun of you because you guys
obviously cut you changed your whole
working style and everything well I will
tell you one of the hardest things for
me is actually to come here in a myth I
was that far in debt so during these
past three years we didn't tell anybody
we just got additional jobs they would
ask and we would just say we're just
trying to get control some stuff so we
kind of kept it internally and it's kind
of easy when you're just folks the two
of us and we didn't have those outside
factors but towards the end and we were
picking up steam and getting there
faster than we thought and at one point
we realized we're gonna make our goal in
two or three months and we said what's
next so we're reading ahead what step
four Step five step six and I'm one of
them was sell the house or not sell the
house but pay off the house and so we
did the math we're like okay we got this
done in five years we'll have the house
paid off and then what and so we said
what we're gonna do then we're like well
we'll sell the house and travel and
we're like why wait
let's sell the house now oh so we got
ahold of one you're a LPS
he came in and told us to clean out a
bunch of clutter in the house and we put
it on the market on a Wednesday showed
it on a Friday had an offer on Monday
and out in four weeks I mean we're down
to first we're down to bread and milk
now we're homeless and two eggs no I
just don't even have a home no home and
that's one way to get the kids to move
out no boomerang kids here there's
nowhere to come back I'd say yeah that's
it so actually when we got to that point
in the EOP helped us a lot
we had another yard so you know you had
the arts at the beginning we had a yard
sale at the end gained us two months so
we won't just clear it all all the stuff
so now we are looking to rent somewhere
and that's fine with us for a little
while while you look build up some time
to travel and change your whole thing
Wow with that equity we went front well
we finished step two and then we went
two three four five yeah just like that
six yeah because you don't have a house
right now but so your plan is to travel
and rent or are you gonna buy again or
what are you gonna do well we're just
gonna look around we're not sure what we
want to do yet we've never had this
freedom to do anything so how old are
you two
fifty one and done fifty one and done
yep I love it how long you been married
28 years have you ever been debt-free in
20 ever never you ever learned any
lessons we've tried we paid things off
and we just never learned the lesson in
it so it's kind of I don't put words in
your mouth but it almost sounds like you
were saying you you started feeling the
freedom and so you just went all the way
through the thing I mean just like I
want to be completely free yes and so
you guys have been pretty conservative
careful people in terms of your
lifestyle I mean you weren't with the
debt the debt was out of control but I
mean but in terms of you know that you
were predictable people and now suddenly
you've kind of gone free spirit on me
here I mean you're having a blast
people ask this why we put the house up
for sale and we're like you know we want
to do it before Christmas because you
know
we don't get in a slow period then when
it's old they're like what are you gonna
do we're like we're gonna go downtown
and rent a place down there and they're
like we've always wanted to do that
they're like I said do it and they go we
can't go yes you can you just gotta put
a different hat on and change your mind
so there's a cool scene in downtown
Lexington right now going though it's
the verification stuff on downtown
Nashville is the same way there's a lot
of happening in there yes there is
well good for you guys I'm proud for you
that's a great store it's very inspiring
thank you it was really the kind of
person we'll shop and I thought well you
know it's $10 I deserve it
$10 well it's only $20 I deserve it
mm-hm and I didn't realize how quickly
that was adding up 109,000 yeah yeah so
after we kind of really got into the
program I just kind of went to the
stores and would just mentally think
that's only $10
okay that's 20 well by the end of the
day I was at 50 and I thought I do that
three and four times a day now I know
what the problem is death by a thousand
cuts it's awful
and actually we were out looking around
the other day we were at a store getting
a table for his mom and I saw this
little clock or something's like $12 I
said gosh that's really cute he goes
yeah that looks like about $3 at a yard
sale that you could invert it to yard
sale dollars it changes the appeal
that's exactly right
seldom-used kitchen items oh my gosh
that's fun you guys are great
congratulations I'm very proud of you
David and Andrea Lexington Kentucky a
hundred and nine thousand dollars paid
off in 36 months making 85 to 155 set
themselves free count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
well done man
oh man that is absolutely awesome